heterogeneity
some scientists love this word and some
not so much
but i think it can be really informative
we know that people age at different
rates and different organs and tissues
also seem to age at different rates but
how do we interpret those differences
and use that understanding to see what
the causes of aging may be
well hello and welcome to the shiki
science show where in this video we'll
be talking about a cool new method that
enables you to estimate the age of a
single cell a single cell
so to break it down we need to first
recap how you can determine biological
age
so i don't just mean the number of days
spent since birth
and then how you can do it for a single
cell and then why you should even care
about it
so let's start with age as i've
established here we go beyond
chronological age
the number of days past since you were
born but instead to biological age
biological age instead of using time as
a measurement it uses different
biomarkers
currently these can range from facial
images to proteins present in your blood
but of relevance to this video
is dna methylation
a type of epigenetic mark that can be
found on dna the use of these
measurements has raised excitement about
the ability to be better at predicting
disease risk which may therefore have
clinical relevance but also to be used
in research to further understand the
aging process
so dna methylation you can think of this
as tags on top of your dna sequence
in particular the sites of methylation
commonly employed in these studies are
at certain genomic sites called cpgs
and it's the cytosine the c that gets
the methylation
by detecting the presence or absence of
methylation at these sites
researchers have been able to generate
epigenetic clocks of age-related dna
methylation changes that show strong
associations with age there are
different ways to track these changes in
methylation but essentially the clocks
are interested in the dna sites and
whether the methyl group is absent or
present
so currently these measurements of dna
methylation used to predict biological
age otherwise known as epigenetic clocks
or aging clocks
they're currently measured by having a
bunch of cells from a tissue sample as
you may have even tested yourself from
blood samples or cheek swabs and then
the dna can be extracted and used to
measure dna methylation
you need to have enough material for
this to work as some of it gets lost
along the way during the processing
and this helps to therefore provide a
more reliable measurement
and so this is from a population of
cells so you get an average across all
of the cells
and so this is the key difference from
looking at single cell approaches where
you would measure the age of a single
cell
but the thing is loss of material and
overall coverage goes down so it's
unlikely you're going to get a
measurement for each of these cpg sites
and this is depicted in this figure here
where you can see that cell a and cell b
cover different regions of a reference
genome so the total dna sequence
whereas in a bulk sample you get data
from many cells and so once you put it
all together you cover a larger region
of the reference genome
and so the other problem this brings is
that if you wanted to compare cell a and
cell b you kind of can't say well
because they didn't overlap that much
and so you have limited distinct
profiles for individual cells
and so if you were looking at
methylation sites in a cell you won't
get a value for each one as you can also
see in this table here
so so far this doesn't really sound like
a reliable way to measure the age of a
cell
but that is what brings us on to this
publication
how to address this problem and actually
get an epigenetic age of single cells
so in this paper they introduce single
cell age a framework for profiling of
epigenetic age using single cell
methylation data so basically getting
this methylation data just on a single
cell instead of having one average data
point
so to develop this framework they had to
make some assumptions and included some
features
so the first problem to solve is the
fact that from a single cell you're not
going to get a measurement point for
each of the different sites of interest
and so to solve that they could use
methylation levels of highly conserved
sites from bulk tissue samples
and then by having it from the bulk data
you could then kind of estimate a
probability of binary methylation at
particular cpg sites in any single cell
from that tissue
so to phrase that in a way that i can
understand
if in the bulk analysis we see a cpg
site that has high methylation then i
would estimate that there would be a
high probability that a single cell
would have a methyl at that site too
and so effectively you can derive a
probability for each cpg site based on
bulk data and that would be your
reference points
and then another consideration is which
cpg sites are more important for
predicting the epigenetic age as
important cpg sites you'd want to have
that information for
so as not all cpg sites are going to be
captured for a single cell they
developed an algorithm to choose a
distinct collection of age-associated
cpgs that are most age-associated so
combining that with the first point you
can estimate the probability of
observing a methylated state at each of
these more important cpg sites for each
age and then compare that with what
values you actually measure for a single
cell that you analyze
and so to get a value of age for a
single cell they assume that each
methylation state is independent and so
they can multiply all the probabilities
together to get an overall likelihood of
the age-associated methylation profile
the age that is most likely is therefore
the predicted epigenetic age of the cell
now since i don't think i did the best
job of explaining this i caught up with
the lead author of this publication alex
trapp who gives a much better
explanation
because we got single cells we don't get
all of the cpg sites there's like less
overlap between different cells and so
does that mean when you predict the age
for a single cell the the cpg sites that
you use are different for each one
absolutely so that was one of the big
things that we had because no method
before that had done that but all these
elastic net like tools essentially you
you give it the methylation matrix that
you have and then it derives you a
couple cpg sites that are informative um
based on the mathematics essentially and
it uses those to predict age but
the assumption there is that all these
cpg psych that it choses should be
available in any type of sample that you
use and if they're not you have a
problem because there are coefficients
associated with these cpg sites and if
you don't have a methylation value to
multiply by that coefficient then
something about the model
will not be as good as if you had all of
those so with single cells there was no
way at least with present methods to do
that since as they're saying um and what
we saw is that the very discordant reads
right so one cell might have
a particular set of cpg sites and then
another cell might have a completely
different one so what we do
is we create this reference data set
that kind of catalogs
a fair amount of cpg sites a million
more than a million if you want you can
it's very flexible so you can use any
type of reference set and the idea is
that it maps how methylation changes in
bulk data
with age so it may increase it may
decrease and may not change and so we
use this reference data set and we
selectively intersect it with the given
single cell so that we only look at the
cpg sites that are covered both in the
single cell and the reference data set
and that's kind of how we get around the
problem and then further from that we we
kind of rank them there's another
algorithm that we use
to rank and filter them based on only
the cpg sites that we're really
interested in so as i said they're most
of them are totally uninformative of age
so either they'll be unmethylated the
whole time or methylated it
also the whole time but we're really
interested in those are the ones that
are dynamic right the ones that change
with age so maybe it'll be unmethylated
or mostly unmethylated at young ages and
then gain and methylation over age or
the opposite
whether or not you understand my
explanation or not
the more important question is was all
the trouble worth it
well in my opinion one of the greatest
advances of having single cell data is
to see heterogeneity and to use that
heterogeneity to explain observations
e.g and i'm being very hypothetical here
let's say two individuals both receive
an epigenetic age of 55.
in person a they have a very narrow age
range whilst in person b is very broad
this may inform that one may be
healthier than the other but i think
what it may suggest is potentially the
strongest causal factor in both cases
more heterogeneity could explain a
senescent cell surrounded by healthy
tissues trying to deal with the damage
whilst having a smaller range may
suggest that on average all of their
cells are just older
this may mean that despite having the
same epigenetic age the suggested
treatment outcomes could differ dot dot
dot as i said i'm being hypothetical
here but this is more of a long-term
consideration anyway
in the study they use their single cell
age
framework for a couple of different
applications the one i think is the
coolest is how they use it to
investigate early mouse development
so this is going from day 4.5 to day 7.5
in an early mouse embryo
and the reason why this was of interest
is because early embryogenesis has been
suggested to be associated with an
initial decrease in biological age to a
point termed ground zero after which all
organismal aging formally begins
and so if you look at this figure here
what you can see is that going from day
4.5 to 7.5 they see a steady and
significant reduction in the predicted
age and so this is consistent with the
notion of a rejuvenation event happening
in early embryogenesis
to erase damage that's accumulated from
the parental gamete cells
so that the newborn embryo can start
fresh from ground zero
other interesting applications would be
to use the single cell approach to have
a better understanding of linking these
methylation sites to potential functions
and one way that they could also do that
is by combining these single cell
epigenetic age measurements with
so-called transcriptomics so seeing what
genes are being expressed in a cell
and so you can basically see the age of
the cell and what it's up to
and this could also be useful for
evaluating the efficiency of cellular
reprogramming such as turning a
differentiated cell into a stem cell and
this process is currently quite
heterogeneous and not necessarily that
efficient
so combining the single cell age and
gene expression in single cells is
something that i expect we will see in
the future
anyway i hope you found this video
interesting
and that you've learned something you
can catch our full-length discussion by
using the link in the description
and with that i'd like to say thank you
to my patreon supporters and thank you
for listening
you